now let's move on to question 5 have a
look at it with me okay now what it adds
on to this is units so here's the first
thing we're gonna do you write down the
two quantities you've got five
centimeters to 20 centimeters okay now
there's two things to do here okay the
first thing is you know it's like a
fraction right so if if I had written
this as a fraction
five centimeters divided by 20
centimeters right
do you notice I've got centimeters on
the top and centimeters on the bottom so
just like any other fraction I can just
get rid of them I can cancel them
whoops so I can start centimeters so
this is interesting
maybe you want to write this down as I
am a note on the side here okay ratios
don't have units okay there are no units
of measurement attached the ratio just
like you see these are just numbers
right here I'm gonna get rid of the
centimeters five to 20
okay can I simplify this anymore I can
I'll divide both by five and I'll say
one to four that's the way that I'd read
that even though one over four is the
same okay now I just want to do one more
example under here let's do B because
sometimes they won't be nice and give
you the same units right so what they've
got there is 12 millimeters right to one
centimeter I think is that right yeah
okay so this just adds one more step I
want to get to this position here where
I have the same units but hey we know
how to convert metric units right
what should I convert to you can choose
to convert this into millimeters or this
into centimeter nice which do you think
would be better centimeters
now you truly can you truly can good
both ways it'll be fine in the end
okay but I like millimeters because I'm
giving you all lovers this would become
one point two centimeters I've to get
rid of that whereas if I write this in
millimeters
what's one centimeter best millimeters
that's okay so your first step is get it
in the same units then you can get rid
of the unit's since then same and then
what should I buy my biggest number is
two so you get six two five okay